allez maintenant à la rapportant de la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
Évelyne Perrot
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui et il
vient de nous l'expliquer pour examiner
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
Vincent capo Canella relative à la
prévisibilité de l'organisation des
services de la navigation aérienne en
cas de mouvement social et à
l'adéquation entre l'ampleur de la grève
et la réduction du trafic
ce texte porte sur un sujet bien
identifié par le grand public les
conséquences sur le trafic aérien des
mouvements sociaux des contrôleurs
aériens au sein de la Direction générale
de l'aviation civile la DGAC le cadre
actuel de ces mouvements sociaux n'est
pas satisfaisant bien que les
organisations syndicales de la DGAC
doivent déposer un préavis de grève 5
jours avant le début du mouvement il est
très difficile d'anticiper l'ampleur
réelle des grèves la DGAC n'a
actuellement aucun moyen de savoir avec
précision combien d'agents décideront
d'y participer
il résulte de cette situation
d'incertitude que la DGAC réalise des
abattements de vol fréquemment bien plus
élevés que nécessaire afin d'éviter des
annulations de dernière minute dites à
chaud qui sont les plus pénalisants pour
les compagnies aériennes et les
passagers la réduction du trafic
consécutive à la grève est donc
disproportionnée au regard de la
participation parfois très faible du
personnel au mouvement le fonctionnement
actuel est déroutant il permet au
contrôleur aériens d'annoncer qu'ils
font grève sans avoir besoin de
réellement passer à l'action les
abattements de vol ayant lieu avant le
début du mouvement les effets recherchés
de la grève en ce qui concerne la
réduction de trafic sont déjà atteints
avant même qu'elle ne commence
parfois la DGAC peut avoir une analyse
trop optimiste de la situation et
annuler en amont moins de vols que ce
qui est nécessaire il faut alors
procéder en urgence à des annulations à
chaud
celle-ci désorganise très fortement le
trafic aérien des passagers déjà arrivé
dans les terminaux et même dans les
avions voient leurs veulent annuler cela
peut donner lieu à des troubles à
l'ordre public lié à la présence dans
les aéroports de nombreuses personnes
courentées face à ces situations
difficiles
c'est incertitude est pénalisante pour
les contrôleurs aériens eux-mêmes en cas
de grève il est en effet possible de
déclencher un dispositif de service
minimum afin d'assurer la continuité du
service public et une certaine partie
des opérations en particulier celle
liées en haut vol vers la Corse et les
outre-mer et au survol du territoire
français
la DGAC est donc souvent obligée de le
déclencher préventivement alors que en
pratique le nombre de grévistes est en
définitive faible si bien qu'il n'aurait
pas été nécessaire de le mettre en place
ce service minimum implique des
réquisitions de personnels les
contrôleurs réquisitionnés ne peuvent de
facto participer au mouvement de grève
quand bien même il l'aurait voulu le
service minimum a aussi un impact qui
fragilise la conciliation entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie privée
parfois le service minimum peut même
être mis en place assez tardivement il
est alors difficile de notifier au
contrôleur leur réquisition et il arrive
dans de rares cas il est vrai que les
forces de l'or de l'ordre doivent s'en
charger cette situation n'est évidemment
pas pleinement satisfaisante
au cours des derniers mois ce système a
montré de façon très claire ses limites
le 11 février dernier en particulier les
contrôleurs ont rejoint une grève de la
fonction publique qui n'avait même pas
été relayée en interne par les syndicats
de la DGAC il en a résulté de nombreuses
annulations à chaud les semaines
suivantes le service minimum a été
fréquemment mis en place ce qui a
dégradé le climat de travail à la DGAC
ce dispositif est en lourd de
conséquence et complexe à organiser tant
pour les contrôleurs aériens que pour
leur direction
la Coupe du monde de rugby et les Jeux
Olympiques approchant à grands pas une
réforme de ce système et donc plus que
jamais nécessaire la proposition de loi
en remédier à cette situation
elle crée une obligation pour les
contrôleurs aériens de se déclarer
individuellement grévistes l'avant
veille du mouvement de grève à midi ils
ont la possibilité de renoncer à leur
participation au mouvement jusqu'à 18h
le même jour
sur la base de ces informations
l'autorité administrative pourra décider
de mettre en place le service minimum
elle disposera pour se faire d'un délai
contraint jusqu'à 18h l'avant veille du
mouvement également
l'information contenue dans des
déclarations dans les déclarations
permettra à l'autorité administrative de
déterminer avec précision le nombre de
vols à annulé les adaptations du trafic
aérien seront donc mieux proportionnés à
l'ampleur du mouvement et les
annulations à chaud nous pouvons
l'espérer éviter
cette déclaration individuelle
s'inscrirait dans le prolongement de
telles déclaration existant déjà dans le
secteur des transports depuis 2007 dans
le transport terrestre régulier de
voyageurs et depuis 2012 pour les autres
travailleurs du secteur aérien les
contrôleurs aériens n'avaient pas en
effet étaient inclus dans le champ de la
loi d'iard de 2012 créant une obligation
de déclaration individuelle de
participation à la grève car elle ne
concernait que le secteur privé et
qu'ils sont des fonctionnaires de la
fonction de la fonction publique d'état
le texte adopté par la commission assure
une protection équivalente entre ces
déclarations individuelles et celles
créées par la loi d'iard en commission
nous avons adopté un amendement
précisant qu'elles seront couvertes par
le secret professionnel
en outre toute utilisation à d'autres
fins que celle prévue par le texte
serait passible de sanctions pénales la
proposition de loi reprend donc le
principe de la loidia mais n'en
constitue pas un simple calque puisqu'il
était en particulier nécessaire de
veiller à l'articulation entre la
déclaration individuelle et le service
minimum pour l'examen de cette
proposition de loi j'ai cherché à
m'inscrire dans une philosophie de
recherche de l'équilibre et de
pragmatisme le texte adopté par la
commission est pleinement en phase avec
cette exigence il est adapté au cadre au
cadre d'exercice des contrôleurs aériens
et répond à ses principales
insuffisances il certes une obligation
pour les contrôleurs la déclaration
individuelle mais également une
obligation pour l'administration puisque
le délai de déclenchement du service
minimum est contraint le texte résout
les principales difficultés du système
actuel aussi bien pour les passagers
puisque moins de vols seront annulés
préventivement et à chaud mais aussi
pour les contrôleurs aériens puisque le
service minimum sera déclenché moins
souvent et plus tôt je souhaite donc que
cette initiative saluée par la
Commission puisse être adopté largement
par notre assemblée que la navette se
poursuive et que nos collègues députés
puissent à leur tour rapidement faire
leur ces propositions constructives et
qui vont dans le bon sens merci
merci la parole va mettre maintenant au
ministre Clément de beau